[Música]
salud en directo américa de france a 24
me acompaña en el estudio marina sardina
marinado y tenemos una muy buena noticia
porque vamos a hablar de un ensayo
histórico en la lucha contra el cáncer
es un fármaco experimental hizo que 12
pacientes con cáncer de colon marina
eliminarán por completo esta enfermedad
de su cuerpo no sé y raúl y se trata de
un hecho inédito histórico y un gran
avance para la ciencia puesto que nunca
antes el cien por cien de los pacientes
tratados en un ensayo habían mostrado
unos resultados tan favorables como fue
la remisión por completo de un tipo de
cáncer esto fue un ensayo que fue
publicado en new england journal of
medicine' una revista científica que si
bien no fue una muestra pequeña es un
tipo de avance que muestra como los
tratamientos de pacientes a través de
fármacos pues pueden mejorar que buscan
mejorar la supervivencia de estos
pacientes y para hablar de ello nos
acompaña el doctor oscar franco él es
profesor de epidemiología y salud
pública en la universidad de berna
buenos días
es un resultado histórico doctor cómo es
posible eliminar este tipo de cáncer un
tipo de cáncer rectal en vacía en 12
pacientes a través de un fármaco llamado
dos tarimas de qué se trata este avance
inédito en la lucha contra el cáncer
así es marina y raúl yo creo que es una
noticia muy positiva me atrevería es más
a invitarlos a marcar esa fecha porque
fue el 5 de junio del 2022 cuando este
estudio fue presentado fue publicado y
realmente no hemos visto nunca antes un
efecto tan impresionante 100% remisión
completa del tumor recibir revisión
completa del cáncer en una muestra
pequeña si es un estudio de fase 2
tenemos que esperar a que se investiguen
otros pacientes a que se tenga un
seguimiento más largo pero lo que
estamos viendo es algo inédito algo que
nunca se había visto que mejoraría no
solamente la supervivencia de los
pacientes sino también la calidad de
vida porque la alternativa es
quimioterapia o cirugía que generalmente
tiene unos efectos muy malos la calidad
de vida de los pacientes vamos a hablar
precisamente de eso doctora muy buena
tarde en qué consiste este tipo entonces
de fármacos como el 2 turley map y como
también actúan a diferencia de los otros
tratamientos tradicionales por ejemplo
como la quimioterapia
si por ejemplo con la quimioterapia o
con la cirugía
los pacientes tienen una calidad de vida
que se afecta la sobrevida pues se
mejora pero realmente no es que
realmente traiga cura en la mayoría de
los pacientes solamente un 10 por ciento
realmente experimentaron a una una
remisión a largo plazo
y la quimioterapia por ejemplo irradia
una región del cuerpo tiene efectos
adversos con la cirugía los pacientes
pueden tener problemas
por ejemplo urinarios sexuales
digestivos pueden tener que llevar una
bolsa una colostomía este tipo de
tratamientos e inmunoterapia son
anticuerpos monoclonales entonces lo que
hacen es actuar a través de nuestro
sistema inmune ayudar a desenmascarar
esas células ayudar al sistema inmune a
poder atacar esas células cáncer y
cancerígenas y ese es el efecto que
tiene no sé si recuerdan cuando donald
trump tuvo coronavirus que decía que le
habían dado unos cócteles que es lo que
han mejorado esos eran también
anticuerpos monoclonales estos son otros
son específicos por unas células de
cáncer pero actúan similar a través de
la función inmune doctor y como decíamos
se trata de una muestra pequeña hay que
tomar con cautela este ensayo y también
cuáles son las contraindicaciones de
este tipo de fármacos
si hasta ahora se está explorando
debemos recordar que los grandes pasos
los pasos más gigantes se dan siempre a
pasos pequeños y yo creo que este es un
paso pequeño hacia una meta muy grande
que es llegar a encontrar una cura para
el cáncer por ahora este es este
tratamiento lo que estamos viendo son un
número limitado de pacientes tenemos que
ver a más largo plazo porque hasta ahora
se han seguido en promedio un año máximo
dos años tenemos que ver si realmente la
remisión dura más tiempo y tenemos que
ver también si podrían tener un efecto
mejor a largo plazo y en una mayor
cantidad de pacientes doctor hay otro
tipo de cáncer que también haya mostrado
remisión gracias a este tipo de
medicamentos
si se había ganado antes para cáncer de
endometrio este medicamento sirve para
un tipo específico de cáncer que tiene
digamos así unas marcas genéticas
específicas y se está investigando a ver
si puede tener un efecto no solamente en
este cáncer colorectal específicamente
del recto sino también para cáncer por
ejemplo de la próstata cáncer del
páncreas y esto podría marcar como digo
un hito en la historia de la medicina
desde la de la cura de casa doctor y el
acceso a este tipo de medicamentos de
terapias alternas a las convencionales
pues ha dejado fuertes
patente fuertes desigualdades
inequidades pues a la hora de hacerlo
debido a su alto coste sobre todo en
países donde pues la sanidad no es
pública o no es universal y gratuita
cuál es la cuál es esto como un efecto
secundario a este a estos tratamientos
de cáncer y cuál es el papel que juegan
las farmacéuticas aquí
así es marina y es que este tratamiento
una inyección cuesta diez mil dólares el
tratamiento completo costaría unos cien
mil dólares y esto no es realmente algo
que se pueda cubrir para todas las
personas entonces por eso es tan
importante seguir insistiendo la
importancia en la cobertura universal de
la seguridad social en la que se le
permite a las personas poder tener
acceso a estos medicamentos las
compañías farmacéuticas establecen
patentes que les ayudan en sus
argumentos a seguir haciendo este tipo
de investigaciones a describir nuevos
medicamentos yo creo que es importante
regresar el papel que juegan los
gobiernos las instituciones las
fundaciones para poder financiar estos
estudios y permitir que las compañías
farmacéuticas cobren un costo mucho
menor pero que están cobrando para
medicamentos como esta pues héctor
gracias como siempre por su tiempo por
acompañarnos a cada miércoles nuestro
espacio de salud de directo
también gracias a marina por traerlas
esta buena noticia a esta sección de
salud nosotros los despedimos para pasar
ahora a saludar a nuestro segundo
invitado el día